this sort of tastes like a Reese's
wrapped in butter which is my ideal
snack
[Music]
so we're gonna bring out some classic
Halloween candies and pair them with
some of the world's best cheese's first
up is a fresh chevre and sour gummy
worms goat's milk cheeses are known for
being really bright acidic minerally
sour gummy worms are also tangy acidic
and all the same things I'm excited
about I'm so excited this is a little
messy yeah yeah I'd eat that for
breakfast yeah how deep just like a bowl
of that but like go shootin yatta our
next pairing is Kanye oveja from Spain
sheep's milk cheese we're pairing that
with the traditional Snickers so
Snickers has a caramel the Nugget when
you put these two together it's like a
milkshake on your palate I could eat a
whole swimming pool of snicker bars I'm
not a huge Snickers fan it's really
delicious so like a milkshake that's a
little bit cheesy I could see this being
a dessert at a high-end restaurant I
don't know if I can finish this one
though this was really intense shoes I
think it's knickers are incomplete
without this cheese so this is Cabot
clothbound cheddar paired with candy
corns what I love about Cabot clothbound
cheddar is it can be both sweet and
salty you get the savory and you get the
sweetness which is more caramel
butterscotch e tones
I love candy corn I am aggressively
neutral on candy corns I like how it
kind of matches in shape yeah this is
classic the classic combo should be
across the shoes they're kind of like
blades right Cheers
that is so good together you're making
me mad
no cheese crumbs everywhere there's way
more fun than thought be delicious I
don't know what you're talking about
it's making me like a candy that I don't
typically like can keep this cheese they
have to take it away this is the king of
cheese parmigiano-reggiano and dot's
what I love about parmigiano-reggiano is
as it ages that develops these really
fruity notes and tropical notes sorry
they're gonna get the lemon the green
the red
each one is gonna bring out that
fruitiness in the parmigiano-reggiano
I hate socks those are the ones I'm not
like excited about when you're trading
candy dots always end up in the do not
want pile there's multiple dots you got
to kind of pick and choose
I'm gonna go red I'm gonna do boring-ass
lemon Oh
Wow oh my god
weird I don't think I like this this has
not been my favorite it's like I'm three
again and I'm eating play-doh but
play-doh that's been left out for a
while okay it's coming together all
right I like it it stuck to my teeth and
I can't get it out it's got like a
fruity pebble finish on the end there
that's a good comparison it's like
fruity pebble good apart weird together
this cheese is a Red Hawk it's a triple
cream from cowgirl Creamery we put this
with chocolate Reese's peanut butter
cups the chocolate peanut butter cups
just take out all the stink and Punk to
it and they just leave that decadence
bleep creaminess on your palate which
makes it a really fun pairing just smell
the cheese for you it's stinky I smell a
distinct jockstrap smell yeah I guess
scratch my armpit smell it smells like a
drawer that I filled with cheese yeah
whoa I like that look oh I love it
I don't like up you have to accept it
like once a goal becomes like mouthwash
just take a deep breath and roll with it
so it sort of tastes like a Reese's
wrapped in butter which is my ideal
snack that's like cutting my throat are
you okay yeah it's it's just a weird
texture I love it it was delicious
I love the cheese alone yeah I love the
candy alone I love the combination i
reccommend steal all your kids candy or
go get it yourself put out six different
fun styles of cheese and have at it with
your friends every one of our palettes
is different play with it and see what
you like for yourself
[Music]